69 years ago the NHS was launched with
her back barter the years have gone by
the dream has started to tarnish what
started as a world leader in technology
care and outcomes is today facing almost
permanent financial difficulties the
morning shift at any in Warwick this is
one of the country's best performing
hospitals even so the constant pressure
and scrutiny is a drain for those who
work here when we get plated in papers
and the news and stuff it's quite
upsetting because I'm not going to be
square to help people I didn't convince
a square to be judged on our staffing
levels and our target sometimes I mean
it's about caring pupation at the end of
the day so why is it that despite all
their hard work and all the money
contributed by taxpayers Britain's
Health Service seems to be in so much
trouble this is a high-tech training
facilities where students come to learn
how to treat patients kind of a virtual
hospital in the real world a lot of
people are worried about the NHS and its
economic crisis as they call it and to
understand why you have to consider a
few figures starting with this one over
the course of the past year 220 billion
pounds was spent in total on health care
that includes social care and care for
those with long-term chronic conditions
but of that by finally the biggest chunk
was health 141 billion pounds in total
now big figures like that can sound
about meaningless out of context so let
me put it into perspective so we don't
get blinded by the numbers back in the
early 80s about ten percent of
everything the government spent went on
health by last year that share of
spending had more than doubled to
twenty-two percent now there's a receive
wisdom that this is all down to
demographics the rising cost of aging
but actually when you dig into the
numbers it's a bit more complicated than
that over the past few years UK health
spending grew at a rate of about four
percent a year but of that only a tiny
fraction was due to demographics far
more important was rising incomes around
the country and even more so other cost
pressures like expensive treatments and
the cost of chronic conditions from all
of that you might have assumed that
health spending was rising at a record
rate but actually will stare
is starting to bite look back recently
and you can see that the five yearly
real growth rate of health spending has
dropped to the lowest level since the
1950s so health care costs are rising
spending is being tightened that's
before you think about social capital e
for the elderly now that's paid for by
local authorities and it's been falling
at a rate of one percent a year in real
terms since 2009 in short there are no
easy answers here but ask the experts
and they'll increasingly tell you the
same thing Britain needs to spend more
on health it's clear that the NHS is
struggling at the moment it's failing on
finances is overspending it's failing on
most of its headline performance
measures so in that sense it is not
sustainable on current levels of funding
so I think the choice for us for the
public for government is we either pay
through poorer performance or we pay
through higher taxes for a better health
service in other words something's got
to give but with costs increasing and
the government trying to cut the deficit
it's just a question of who blinks first
at Conway Sky News
[Music]